شكرا لك ليلى ومرحبا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه
النافذه للتحليل العسكري لمجريات حرب
اسرائيل على قطاع غزه فيها معنا المحلل
العسكري اللواء فايز دويري اهلا وسهلا بك
لواء فايز ولكن سنبدا على الخارطه في
تحليل لابرز مجريات هذا اليوم مع الزميل
محمود الكن ال نعم السسي كثير من الاحداث
المتسارعه اليوم وفي عده مناطق نتحدث عن
اليمن نتحدث عن غزه دعونا نبدا من هذه
الخريطه من اليمن هنا كانت احدى السفن قد
اصيبت ب اما بصاروخ او مسيره في شمال غرب
ميناء المخا هنا في هذه النقطه حسب
الانذار البحري الذي اطلق هذه النقطه في
شمال غرب المخا حوالي 24 عقده بحريه نتحدث
عن حوالي
42 كيلومترا وبحسب ذلك الانذار فان
السفينه اصيبت من الجانب الايمن هذا
بالنسبه لما يحدث حاليا في البحر الاحمر
الكثير ايضا من الشركات قالت انها لن تمر
عبر مضيق باب المندب منها شركات ناقلات
النفط وغيرها من الناقلات الاخرى التجاريه
وبالتالي هذه كانت الاحداث المتسارعه هنا
في باب المندب الان نتجه الى قطاع
غزه في قطاع غزه طبعا المعارك محتدمه شمال
وجنوبا جنوبا في هنا في خان يونس نتحدث عن
محاولات كانت الضغط
الاسرائيليه من شارع كيسوفيم باتجاه شارع
صلاح الدين سابقا ما مازال محور الضغط
مستمرا لكن المقاومه كان لها اشتباكات
عنيفه ما زالت مع القوات الاسرائيليه
المتوغلة
التوغل لكن ما زلنا في توازن بين مناطق
التوغل سواء جنوبا او شمالا منذ عده ايام
بهذا اللون
الاصفر الحدث الابرز كان بالصور التي ظهرت
خلال الساعات الماضيه والتي نشرتها كتائب
القسام الان نود ملاحظه اللون الاصفر
التوغل كنا دوما نتحدث عن التوغل وليس
مناطق السيطره اللافت في الم الموضوع هو
هنا ابراج الندى اذا ما شاهدنا هذه النقطه
فهذه النقطه هي اصلا ضمن المناطق الصفراء
المستمره منذ الايام الاولى على الاقل في
شمال القطاع وهي مناطق للتوغل الاسرائيلي
منذ البدايه منذ بدايه العمليات البريه
شاهدنا منذ قليل ايضا عمليات التمشيط
الاسرائيليه التي نشرها جيش الاحتلال
والتي يقوم في فيها بالانتقال من مبنى الى
مبنى في محاوله لتمشيط المبنى والتاكد من
ان هذه المناطق خاليه العمليه التي صورت
في فيديو القسام والتي استهدفت فيها اليه
عسكريه بصواريخ الكورنيت كانت هنا في هذا
اللون الاصفر بالتالي تساؤلات عن التمشيط
وكيفيه العمل وهل كان بالفعل
عمليه تاكد من عدم وجود مقاتلين في هذه
المنطقه هذا احدث التساؤلات يشير ايضا اذا
كذلك ان النفق الذي اعلن عنه اكتشافه قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي كان هنا حوالي 40
مترا من معبر
ايريز ونهايته على بعد
حوالي كيلومتر و 200 متر في حين انه اعلن
ان النفق كان طوله حوالي 4 كترات لذلك ععد
تساؤلات حول الروايه الاسرائيليه بهذا
الشان ا
دعونا ايضا المناطق الشجاعيه هناك محاولات
اسرائيليه ما زالت مستمره بعمليه التوغل
هنا باتجاه عبر شارع بغداد محور صلاح
الدين محاوله الوصول الى الساحه ساحه
فلسطين لكن ما تزال الاشتباكات مستمره
الفيديوهات التي تصدرت المشهد اليوم تحكي
لنا الكثير عن التوغل وهل كان هناك بالفعل
سيطره وكيفيه عمل هذا التوغل هذا ما
سنناقشه معك ال السي واللواء فايز دوي
شكرا لك محمود لواء فايز طبعا اليوم الصور
التي حصلت عليها الجزيره ربما اوضح صور
تبين المعارك التي تخوضها المقاومه
الفلسطينيه القسام في غزه من النقطه صفر
مع الجنود الاسرائيليين حتى كثر توقفوا
عند طريقه التصوير لنتحدث عن هذه الصور
لواء
فائز
حدث الان الان هذا الفيديو في عده لقطات
مميزه ومختلفه تم مهاجمه ثلاث دبابات من
زوايا مختلفه الدبابه الاولى كانت من حاله
الثبات الدبابه الثانيه من حاله الحركه
وكانت المقاربه زاويه 90 درجه الدبابه
الثالثه كانت من حاله الحركه ولكن كانت من
زاويه 180 درجه اي مواجهه والناقله الجند
كانت في حاله حركه من زاويه 90 درجه
وبالتالي
هناك عده لقطات ثم جاءت لقطه استخدام تي
بي جي ضد احد المباني وشاهدنا
الجندي الموجود خلف النافذه وخلف وخلف
الستاره ثم كانت اللقطه المعبره جدا
وستاتي بعد لحظات على ما اعتقد وهو
استهداف مجموعه من الجنود كانوا يحتم في
جانب احد الدبابات وهذا كان عددهم تقريبا
حوالي عش من الافراد وهو طاقم الدباب نعم
طاق طاقم الدبابه الرامي او القناص كان
موفق جدا في في اختيار الهدف حي توجه
تاندم الى الجنود المحتمين بجانب الدبابه
لانه بعد ان يتم القضاء عليهم او اصابتهم
تبقى الدبابه في مكانها وتصبح صيدا سهلا
في مرحله لاحقه ثم جاءت الصور المعبره جدا
وهي صور هذه ثلاث جفات تقوم مع بعض ب ساحب
دبابه لان وزنها اكثر من 65 طن وحتى جارفه
بالخلف تساعد الجارفه الاخرى وهي يمكن
تبيان حجم الاصابات في هذه الدبابه هذ هذه
اصيبت بقذيفه بقذيفه ياسين ولكن حتى هذا
التدمير ليس كلي هناك دبابات دمرت بصوره
اكبر هذه اللقطات اللي فعلا لقطات معبره
هي محاوله اسعاف احد الجرحى وهنا اعتقد
انه فارق الحياه لكن الملفت هذه صور اخذت
من مسافه قريبه جدا يعني لا يمكن للقسام
او غيره ان ياخذ هذه الصوره انما كانت هذه
الصوره من قبل كاميرا عائده للجيش
الاسرائيلي لكن وصلت بطريقه ما الى القسام
سواء اثناء ارسالها او تم السيطره والقاء
القبض او قتل او اسر او جرح من كان يحمل
هذه الكاميرا الجيش الاسرائيلي لم ينشر اي
شيء قامت القسام بالنيابه وقدمت هذه
الصوره لتكشف حقي
ان الجيش الاسرائيلي يخفي كثيرا من ماساته
في غزه مجموعه اخرى من الصور ايضا حصلت
عليها الجزيره اعتقد الان ربما ستظهر
لاستهداف عربات جيب اسرائيليه قرب ابراج
الندى في منطقه بيت لهيه يعني ربما هذه
المره الاولى التي يتم فيها تحديد كان
التوقيت كثير موفق جدا لانه جاءت بعد
تصريح الجيش الاسرائيلي ان هذه الم منطقه
ابراج الندى او هي ما يعرف عزبه بيت حانون
الى الشمال الغربي من بيت حانون انها
منطقه امنه ومنطقه تم سيطره عليها فجاء
نشر الفيديو بعد هذا التصريح واستخدم فيها
لاحظه مجموعه من الاليات الان تم اختيار
الهدف وهو اخر هدف وهي سياره الجيب وتم
استهدافها بصاروخ صاروخ كورنيت لكن لماذا
ستم استخدام الكورنيت انا في البدايه كنت
اعتقد ياسين لكن بعد متابعه الفيديو وجدت
ان مساره لولبيا وبالتالي يعني انه كورنيت
الكورنيت مداه 5.5 م هذه هذه الاليات اللي
امام الجيب هي محميه بنظام تروفي وبالتالي
بالكور نظام التروفي غير فاعل ضد
ال الاسلحه قصيره المدى لانه مدى بد
الاستهداف يعني قد يكون يقاس بالثانيه ان
لم يكن اقل في محال الكورنيت مداه 5.5 م م
فهذه هذا النظام معطف الريح يسمى او
الستار الواقع او تروفي فاعل ضد الكورنيت
فبالتالي مستخدم الكورنيت كان ذكيا جدا
وموفقا في استهداف الاليه غير المحميه
بنظام تروفي لواء فايز ما دلالات ان يتم
بث هكذا صور ل المعارك بهذا الشكل في هذه
المرحله من الحرب هذه رساله واضحه جدا بان
القسام لا يزال وبقيه الفصائل تملك
السيطره منظومه القياده والسيطره حتى ليس
بابعاد
الومان كنترول لا كوماند كنترول كيشن
كبيوتر في المستويات الاربعه لانه لا يمكن
ان تتم اجراء عمليات هذا التصوير دون
تكامل المنظومه وهذه تدل على ان هيئه ركن
القسام وغيرها لا تزال تعمل بمنتهى
الكفاءه وهي صاحبه اليد العليا عندما تكون
يكون النزال ما بين القسام وبقيه الفصائل
وما بين جيش الاحتلال جيش الاحتلال لا
يفلح الا في ارتكاب المجازر
نشاهد ايضا صور وزعها الجيش
الاسرائيلي بينت وجود الجيش في مناطق
شوارع لا نعرف اين في غزه بغض بغض النظر
الخارطه الت الخارطه التي عرضت قبل قليل
ملونه باللون الاصفر تقريبا 25% من مساحه
غزه قطاع غزه تم الدخول لها والاليات
موجوده فيها بغض النظر موجوده في اطراف
الشجاعيه موجوده في الرمال موجوده في ب
سيله في غيرها هي موجوده لا نستطيع ان
ننكر هناك الخارطه ملونه اللون الاصفر
يعني هذه مناطق دخلت الجيش وبالتالي هذه
الصور قد تعرض وهي موجوده لكن الذي يعيب
هذه الفيديوهات انها دائما تتحدث عن شق
واحد من المعادله المعادله ذات شقين جيش
الاحتلال وفصائل المقاومه دائما وابدا هذا
الفيديو رقم اربعه او خمسه اتابعه ولله
جميعها تقوم كانهم في منطقه تدريب ليس في
معركه لاني لم اشاهد اثرا لشق الاخر من
المعادله وبالتالي هذه يعني اعتبرها
بالنسبه لي كمحلل واتبعها بصوره تامه
وتابعها اعتبرها نوع من التس هل من دلاله
لعمليات الاقتحام هنا ن لا يوجد اي دلاله
هل هناك من يقاتل امامهم هي عمليات عرض
قوه رسائل للداخل الاسرائيلي اننا نفعل
شيء لكن انا كمحلل ومتابع اعتبرها فتره
اشترا بالنسبه لي اريح اعصابي اجدها لو
قارنا ب بين المشهدين مشهد ما تبثه القسام
وهذه المشاد القسام يبث طرفي المعادله
السهم الاحمر يؤشر
للدبابه ومن ثم يظهر الرامي ونشاهد مسار
القذيفه ونشاهد نتيجه التدمير اذا الصوره
امامي واضحه هنا امامي نصف الحقيقه فقط
الجيش الاحتلال يتحرك في منطقه ما يطلق
كانه في مناوره او و في المدينه التي تم
اعدادها في صحراء النقب لاجل اغراض
التدريب الجزء الثاني من الشق الثاني من
المعادله مغيب لهذا السبب اقول لك عندما
انظر لها اشعر بنوع من المتعه
لاني اكتشف مدى سخف من انتج هذه الافلام
اشكرك جزيل الشكر اللواء فايز دويري ختام
هذه الفقره العسكريه الخاصه بتداعيات حرب
اسرائيل على غزه نعود الى غرفه الاخبار
وليلى لمتا بعد التغطيه